this is a mountain made of literal trash
in New Delhi India a disgusting smelly
enormous heap of mostly plastic trash
that makes life a living hell for those
around
[Music]
it
But Trash mountain in India is just one
of many there are mountains of trash
like this in poor countries all over the
world in Malaysia La Ethiopia but here's
the thing all this trash is not from the
locals the trash mountain in New Delhi
is not just trash made by people in New
Deli no no no the majority of this trash
is from Rich countries ah yes rich
countries produce a ton of trash and
then they ship it off to poor countries
poor countries have become the West's
personal garbage can thousands of people
risk their lives collecting trash in one
of India's largest landfills America
can't process all the trash it produces
nor does it want to so why not ship it
off to poor countries that don't have a
choice they are so desperate that they
will be thrilled to take it off our
hands and so America has been secretly
shipping their plastic trash since the
'90s
and from there all this trash ends up
getting burned into the air that we
breathe it gets thrown into our oceans
infecting the fish we eat and infesting
the lives of the poor people that have
to live in this trash that when Plastics
float out at Sea they actually act as a
contaminant sponge so a lot of
contaminants want to be attached to
something hard and plastic is a great
substrate for which these contaminants
can associate with when animals eat
plastic they can get this dose of
contaminants that can be potentially
detrimental for their system it's
causing everything from tuberculosis to
cancer in the people who live near these
giant plastic dumps the smell just
terrible and I know that this is soal
melting plastic is one of the very
important process to recycle Plastics
and uh this mail uh I can feel this is
make me feel uncomfortable
immediately
[Music]
and does the water also bring the more
fumes out yeah fumes we can not also
breathe properly because of this fumes
like ammonia and carbon dioxide and some
kind of uh like rent eggs you know
rotten yeah everything is De decomposing
stay dangerous and this is the economics
of third world
[Music]
trash as a responsible upstanding
American you always make sure that you
toss your soda bottles yogurt cups and
plastic straws into those shiny blue
recycling bins you've been taught your
entire life to reduce reuse and recycle
what more will you do we must reduce all
this garbage we're created until we get
our very own blue box I'm organizing
recycling in our building hey us cliff
dwellers want this land to have a future
too it's worth it I'm reusing this
plastic jug and making it into a funnel
and a tool holder jars nuts bolts screws
Nails reuse it for the future it's worth
it reduce reuse recycle it's worth it it
is worth it you sincerely believe that
whatever you put into the recycling bin
is going to go to a nice clean recycling
center where your dirty trash is
magically transformed into fresh new
Plastic Products like shampoo bottles
milk Jaws toothpaste caps the sky is the
limits but what they don't want you to
know is that recycling today is pretty
much useless that's because there's
actually only two types of plastic that
is considered recyclable in the US pet
number one and hdp number two which are
what most bottles and DRS are made of
can all plastic be recycled no in order
for something to be recycled the first
thing that you have to know is is there
somebody that wants to buy it to turn it
into new products there has to be a
market for that material what are some
general things that are good to recycle
that are plastic so there there are kind
of um four types of plastic that we
accept in our program and those are
water and soda bottles milk jugs
detergent containers tubs for things
like yogurt or butter everything else
from styrofoam to plastic wrap to
grocery bags cannot be recycled because
they either produce too many toxins or
they kind of just fall apart after going
through the recycling process so in
total only around 9% of all plastic is
ever recycled that's right all that
effort all that work all those recycling
cans for just 9% that's because
recycling is just too expensive and
labor intensive plastic needs to be
separated out by type and color you
can't recycle an orange detergent jug
with a clear soda bottle and most
recycling centers aren't willing to put
the money into doing this especially
when it's just cheaper for companies to
use new plastic from oil and gas so what
do they do with all this worthless
plastic waste well some of it gets
burned right now the US is burning six
times the amount of plastic it's
Recycling and these incinerators pump
out a whole bunch of cancer causing
chemicals into communities nearby
plastic might also get buried the
manager of a recycling center in Oregon
reported that containers bags packaging
strawberry containers yogurt cups none
of this plastic will be turned into new
plastic things all of it is buried there
are mass Graves of plastic all over
America and they won't fully decompose
for 500 years and when it's not burned
or buried all this plastic waste is sent
[Music]
overseas
the the leading countries that pollute
the ocean I think number one was
Philippines I was going to say Southeast
why would southeast Asia have that issue
these are mountains of plastic trash in
Malaysia all this trash come from places
from around the world for example this
bottle is from the United States of
America this packaging is from Germany
this bag is from the United Kingdom
India turkey Thailand Malaysia all these
countries have become The Dumping
grounds for America's plastic garbage
but it wasn't always like this see up
until 2017 the US sent most of its
plastic Wass to China and it was working
really well for a couple of decades but
after a while things got out of hand
China was given the good recyclable
plastics like milk jugs and soda bottles
but they were also given a ton of junk
plastic that couldn't be recycled that
they either had to burn or dump in a
landfill and this ended up destroying
their environment so in 2017 China
banned importing American Plastics but
China said says it's not taking in that
garbage anymore a decision that has
changed the way countries around the
world have to handle their waste a
decision most weren't ready for and so
America needed a new Dumping Ground and
they found it in the neighboring poor
countries and so America started selling
their garbage to developing countries in
Southeast Asia like India Thailand and
Malaysia these same countries were
already mismanaging over 70% of their
own plastic trash and yet here they were
eagerly buying America's trash as well
why because to them American trash was
like pure gold think about it recycling
companies in these poor countries can
buy one ton of plastic from America for
$150 they can process it melt it down
into pellets and then sell this recycled
plastic back to America for $800 that's
an over 500% return and for a poor
country it was too sweet of a
proposition to pass up and plus for
Western manufacturers being able to slap
a recycled plastic label on a product is
valuable so as a poor waste management
company in Malaysia or even turkey
you'll take on all the plastic you can
get and all that plastic that you can't
recycle because it's too dirty or
whatever there is no environmental
regulations in these countries unlike
America so you'll just dump it in your
local trash mountain or in the ocean or
you'll burn it into the air and no one
will bat an eye and this will end up
having horrible effects on your
environments just like it did for
China
fore
when Kim identified the culprit he
nearly lost
[Music]
hope everywhere you go in this
neighborhood hugging the edge of a Giant
Mountain of waste you're costed by the
smell of decomposing garbage in this
case right here it smells like toxic
ammonia these trash mounts are
constantly bursting into flames because
of batteries exploding or just because
of the heat from the
Sun
and the people who live near these
plastic dumps in Malaysia are starting
to develop a whole host of health
problems because of these fires end of
2017 my community start finding we are
encounter bad a quality a lot of people
be wake out at night time and the ages
look so hazy always both fell sick it's
hard to breathe here very hard to
breathe here you guys live here yes um
is it hard to Breathe Here yes yes do
people in their families have health
problems because of the trash in the air
the trash and the air and the pollution
sometimes they burn it to get rid of the
trash then the air quality become worse
they'll catch AA too like their
grandparents the burning of plastic will
release volatile organic compounds which
constant exposure will bring off cancer
of various kinds one study found that
half of the Plastics found in India's
trash Mountain contains a flame
retardant that causes neur ological
reproductive and developmental harms
garbage Pickers work all day separating
out Plastics because they literally have
no better
opportunity
all these waste Pickers who are actually
the poorest of the poor and the most
backward classes they they have no other
option of for livelihood they don't have
any other skills so only the very poor
people will actually become a was picker
these people live around a landfill
because that is their source of
livelihood so while we can criticize and
say that why do they live here if it is
so hazardous they they are they have so
many injuries because they pick waste
from the landfills or dump sides with
their bare hands there are Sharps lying
there it infects them then a daily
inhalation of all those toxic fumes in a
landfill I mean you can imagine when you
pass A dala or a garbage dump you have
to close your nose people who are
working 24x7 on a landfill you can
imagine they have headaches they have
nausea they have gastro entries spinal
problems I think that's a part of their
daily
[Music]
life almost every piece of plastic ever
made is still on on the planet in some
form or another all right guys we're on
the beach outside the
Raga and it is heavy am of
plastic this is insane check this
out so can a network of trash barriers
clean the world's most polluted
rivers and are cleaner Rivers the key to
a plastic free ocean so this is really
the the bank of
of the river here and it's quite
astounding to think that if we estimate
there may be 10 million to 30 million
kilos of plastic flowing through this
Gorge every single year our plastic
coffee cup lids toothbrushes and chip
bags can be found on every corner of the
planets Plastics been found on beaches
and seas around the world in incredibly
remote places um I talked to one
researcher who described going to a tiny
like little rocky outcropping um aptly
named inaccessible Island near
Antarctica his crew went ashore in one
of their Zodiacs and there they found
plastic bottles you've all heard reports
about the North Pacific Garbage Patch
and contrary to that film which we just
saw it really doesn't look anything like
the the the plastic there does not look
like what they showed in the film you
actually don't find a lot of plastic
bags there because they get broken up by
the time they get that far out but it's
an area in the Pacific where currents
and atmospheric conditions um create a
slow Vortex that kind of traps uh that
pulls in and traps trash from North
America and Asia a lot of it's from Asia
um and actually this is a little
misleading because really what it looks
like is sort of a dog bone shape with
two two convergence zones one near Asia
one near um the US North America um what
doesn't eventually stuff gets trapped
there for a while and then eventually
gets spit back out and you ends up um
often on beaches and you know
unfortunately this is not the only such
place there are at least five similar
gyers um around the world what's leaving
land heading out to sea is all the
single-use packaging it's the straws the
bags the bottles the cup lids the stir
sticks all this junk that we used once
and throw away a plastic bottle lead in
California would get to Japan in about 3
to 5 years and come back across the
northern half of the North Pacific that
plastic has been found in the stomachs
of seabirds every single Albatross that
you see across this landscape has been
fed plastic so as you open it up you can
see that's incredible all that plastic
that's inside this
bird
175 pieces of plastic including bottle
tops balloon ties and a doll's
arm these are all of the pieces of
plastic taken from that bird's stomach 3
days ago it represents about 5 to 8% of
the bird's body weight that's the
equivalent of me carrying around 3 to 5
kg of plastic in my stomach and in the
ocean it's literally snowing
microplastics microplastics are some of
the smallest pieces of plastic found in
the ocean these microplastics can be as
small as the width of a human
hair we measured microplastics
throughout the water column starting
from the sea surface and going down to
1,000 M using our robotic vehicle
we found microplastics at every depth we
sampled in Monterey Bay the most common
type of microplastic we found in the
deep sea was pet now most plastic in the
ocean doesn't stay in the form that you
see it in this bird or as the the uh
movie on the plastic bag showed most of
it actually gets uh broken down into
little bits little tiny pieces and that
poses a whole other set of issues um
it's it's these little bits seem to be
affecting the o ocean ecology there was
just a report showing that um a
particular variety of sea insect is uh
depositing eggs on these little bits in
much higher numbers than ever before who
knows what that's going to do to the
ecosystem out there uh but the other and
sort of more worrisome immediately
worrisome thing is that these tiny bits
absorb toxins that are already in the
ocean they're like sponges and they pick
up things like pcbs and ddts persistent
organic pollutants that have been in the
oceans that were banned you know three
decades four decades ago but persist in
the ocean and um and get absorbed onto
these little plastic
bits now for this problem this might be
the poster child this is a lantern fish
um it's much less charismatic than the
albatross but its mothers love them um
they're deep sea dwellers that um come
up at night to feed on Plankton on the
surface and research suggests that um as
along with the Plankton they're also
eating these little plastic bits a
recent study found 9% of those sampled
had plastic in their in their uh guts
the concern is if the toxins on these
Plastics can sorb off of the bits into
the fish's tissue you have a vehicle for
moving these toxins up the feed food
chain as they are eaten by bigger and
bigger and bigger fish and eventually by
us and the worst part is that we all
know this and yet you and I will keep
buying plastic plastic has become too
ingrained in our modern lives to give it
up so what is the solution to all of
this well as you know the problem with
recycling is that it's too picky it
requires too much sorting too much
Manpower but what if there was a way to
recycle where you didn't have to sort
through good and bad plastic well that
is what one company called aduro clean
Technologies is working on aduro has
pounded a new way to recycle plastic
where instead of having to sort through
plastic all you have to do is feed in a
bunch of plastic the plastic gets
crushed into simple granules the plastic
granules are then fed into a reactor
that breaks down the plastic long strong
molecular chains into something called
called hydrocarbon molecules the exact
same type of molecule that is found in
fuel and boom just like that you just
turn plastic waste into literal fuel
that can be used to run anything from
Cars and Trucks to ships and airplanes
no expensive pre-or post-processing
required think about how powerful that
is turning plastic into fuel without all
the downsizes and high energy costs
whereas traditional recycling uses
either thermolysis solsis or dissolution
our Dural is based on a brand new
approach that they patented called
chysis and the best part is that they've
already proven this new approach works
in the lab and they're working on their
first pilot buildout this year but what
I think is really cool is their business
model see instead of just running these
recycling reactors themselves they plan
on using a licensing model that way
aduro can scale up effortlessly compared
to if they were to try to run all these
recycling operations themselves and
because aduro pented this Tech they're
going to have a monopoly over all of it
think of it as kind of like the
McDonald's franchising model before
Recycling and aduro was selected for
Shell's Game Changer program by the way
aduro is the paid sponsor of this video
and aduro is a public company listed on
the stock markets so if you want to
learn more about them you can check them
out by scrolling down and clicking the
link below scroll down and click the
link below now follow disclaimer and
disclosures linked down there as well
stay dangerous and we'll see you in the
next
[Music]
one